what do you think is the most likely
coveted scenario going forward
uh besides vaccines work and it goes
away within the year as everybody gets
vaccines in other words where is the
risk and how do we spot it
um i actually
felt and i it was hard it's hard to
separate out
my assessment from my hope but it really
felt even before the vaccines were being
rolled out
that we were going to end up with this
thing becoming
endemic in the population and losing
virulence and becoming one of these
coronary viruses that circulates and
kids get exposed to
and like they do for colds and um that
it would
become less and less of a deal
i still hope that's a possibility i
don't know where to put the
probabilities at
well i would say the details of that
scenario
matter a lot and there's one way in
which i think that's a horrifying
scenario
and that the you know effectively adding
another
influenza um same influence
well i know but within that it becoming
endemic
and us being regularly uh infected by it
could potentially be a disaster or it
could you know descend into a level of
virulence where it would be
a nuisance still a huge setback but
nonetheless
it could be a tolerable one i think
there's a possibility that the vaccine
as ill-advised as launching into a
massive vaccine
vaccination campaign that is not
evolutionarily well
thought out is it's actually possible
that this could work
and that the escapees will have
downsides associated with them
evolutionarily that what kind of
escapees they were talking about virus
virus virus escaping susceptibility
but i think it's actually very likely
that what happens is that the arms race
produces the natural
counterpart on our side which is that
you know we will be generating vaccines
rapidly it will be escaping and we will
be chasing the virus
and we will learn a lot about
the consequences of repeated vaccination
um so anyway there are a lot of
scenarios and i would say
many possibilities are open here
including presumably ones we haven't
thought of
yep um but i'm you know
cross your fingers that uh this
vaccination campaign and there are ways
in which
if it makes any sense it hasn't been
explained to us
how it does the vaccinating of people
who've had covid
still doesn't make any sense to me right
um and it's a lot of people
so why are we exposing them to the
hazard of a vaccine we know nothing
about the long-term implications of that
seems indefensible yep but um
i guess we'll see yep
[Music]